[Music]
foreign
[Music]
slave lady busty Alexa
oh Janet hey there yeah
still not used to it uh Hey what if I an
already amazing person who definitely
belongs here wanted to learn even more
about how to be a good person is one of
these nerds like a teacher or a life
coach or an Instagram fitness model or
something
debate over TV's best shows will rage
Eternal but what we found here at Rotten
Tomatoes is that not every season of
those best series are created equal
why people love Molly black people also
love Molly
[ __ ]
some of the best series of all time ran
long enough to see their season scores
land all over the map so we decided to
collect the best of the best and rounded
up the seasons with perfect 100 Tomato
Meter scores
[Applause]
lastly while several 100 Seasons might
have enough reviews to be included on
this list they don't meet all the
certified fresh eligibility requirements
just yet but we'll keep watching them so
sit back and relax as we count down the
best 100 TV seasons
foreign
[Music]
the babysitters Club season one
a group of friends launch a babysitting
business starring Sophie Grace momona
tomata Shea Rudolph and created by
Rachel shukert critics say sweet sincere
and full of Hope the babysitter's club's
grounded approach honors its source
material while updating the story for a
new generation this is my cousin Toby
he's visiting from Canada hi want to
hang out with us later
I can't my co-baby sitter and I need to
have some one-on-one time if she has
time for me
[Music]
she seems pretty busy
here I'll give you my number text me if
you change your mind
said he's gonna be a burger Garden later
slamming Burgers so
probably put a pin in the Bikini
shopping it's freezing anyways
so much for fun in the sun well I'm
inviting my new friend Alex and his
cousin to join us do you think Scott
will like them Stacy why are you
training yourself inside out for this
completely average guy who you barely
know
I'm sorry to say it Marianne but you're
just not as what as mature as you well
at least I'm mature enough to do the job
I was hired to do I knew Marianne was
right
I hadn't been a great babysitter
or a great friend
but Scott was worth it
wasn't he number nine Yellow Jackets
season one
Yellow Jackets Tells A Narrative of a
team of wildly talented High School
girls soccer players who survive a plane
crash deep in the Ontario Wilderness the
series Chronicles their descent from a
complicated but thriving team to warring
cannibalistic Clans while also tracking
the lives that they have attempted to
piece back together starring Melanie
Linsky Juliette Lewis Christina Ritchie
and created by Ashley Lyle and Bart
Nickerson critics say a genre mashup
that blends smoothly Yellowjackets
presents an absorbing mystery with
plenty of Sting
happy Friday Mrs de Janeiro
time for your meds
we've been a good girl today
still on a hunger strike I see
you know
you're never gonna get your strength
back up if you don't eat
Gloria
did we have another accent
I have told you you just have to press
the button and someone will come
I just changed those sheets
you know
I think the morphine might be upsetting
your tummy
don't [ __ ] with me
foreign
number eight the good Place season two
when Eleanor finds herself in the
afterlife she's both relieved and
surprised that she's made it into the
good place but it doesn't take long for
Eleanor to realize that she's there
buying the steak she hides in plain
sight from the good places architect
Michael and his all-knowing assistant
Janet her seemingly perfect neighbors
and open-hearted soulmate helper realize
that it's never too late to change with
the help of her new friends and a few
enemies Eleanor becomes determined to
shed her old way of life in hopes of
discovering a new one in the afterlife
starring Kristen Bell Ted Danson Jamila
Jamil and created by Michael sure
critics say by voluntarily blowing up
its premise the good place sets up a
second season that proves even funnier
than its first so Aristotle believes
your character is voluntary because uh
are you ignoring me right now it's day
two of our ethics lessons and you're
already tuning out no sorry I just got
distracted for a second the last thing I
remember you saying is
nothing can you start from the beginning
okay I need a little break can we take a
walk or something maybe get some clam
chowder
[Music]
where is everyone
who knows maybe they finally figured out
clam chowder is disgusting because it's
basically a Savory latte with bugs in it
number seven Fargo season two
in this Anthology series inspired by the
1996 film each season follows a mostly
new cast of characters who get involved
with murder investigations in different
Midwestern towns with seemingly
unrelated crimes sometimes being
connected in some way starring Patrick
Wilson Kirsten Dunst Jesse plemons and
created by Noah Holly critics say season
two of Fargo retains all the elements
that made the series an award-winning
hit successfully delivering another
Stellar Saga powered by fascinating
characters cheeky cynicism and just a
touch of the Absurd
except
here are two of my men
assaulted just this morning in the
appropriation of Donuts by your oldest
attacked in peacetime
During the period of deliberation
without provocation
oh I was provoked
my sons will abide
let's see see that that's the problem
with the family business now if one of
my men defies me
puts a deal in Jeopardy I take his arm
if he talks how to turn I take his
tongue
but you your children your grandchildren
what are you willing to do to show us
your commitment
I'll deal with my son
partnership will oh come on you're gonna
let this guy come here and disrespect us
disrespect pop quiet bunch of fruits and
ties and your pocket protectors I'll
pick my teeth take them out
number six hacks season one
a dark mentorship forms between Deborah
Vance a legendary Las Vegas comic and an
entitled Outcast 25 year old comedy
writer starring Jean Smart Hannah
einbinder Caitlin Olson and created by
Lucia anello Paul W downs and Jen
statsky critics say a prickling debut
that pulls few punches hacks definitely
balances its sharp critiques of the
comedy world with more intimate moments
all the while giving the incomparable
Jean Smart a role worthy of her talents
and an excellent partner in Hannah Ein
binder
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
sending your son to the woods with a
bunch of other horny gay teens the only
thing you're going to convert him to is
from a top to a bottom
okay now that's a better joke
oh my God that's why you almost just
killed me no no we keep it on the dad uh
Senator Rogers has been in the closet so
long his wife keeps trying to donate him
to Goodwill okay to be clear these are
all problematic
what if it's something like Senator
Rogers has been in the closet so long
all his friends are mothballs mothballs
Senator Rogers has been in the closet so
long he's mothballs
yeah yes that's it that's it
okay
um can I go now no
you're hired
wait what
I said I didn't want the job yeah well
you need it write me 20 jokes before
tomorrow morning
oh and nothing about pantyhose or the
Challenger explosion I've done them all
foreign
number five master of none season two
Dev continues his work as a struggling
actor but something happens it may
change his life forever starring Ravi
Patel lenaway and Aziz Ansari who
created the show with Alan Yang critics
say master of none's second season picks
up words predecessor left off delivering
an ambitious batch of episodes that
builds on the show's premise while
adding surprising twists
my
I'm gay
you what
I'm gay
I've always been gay
but I'm still the same person
I'm still your daughter
nothing's changed
me being gay is like touching her trophy
some black people think being gay is the
choice
and when they find out that their kid is
gay
they try to figure out what they did
wrong
I just I don't want life to be odd you
it is hard enough being a black woman in
this world now you want to add something
else to
it's not like this was my choice
number four insecure season one
Issa and Molly are best friends who deal
with their own real life flaws their
insecurities come to the fore as
together they cope with an endless
series of uncomfortable everyday
experiences starring Yvonne OG J Ellis
and Issa Rae who created the show with
Larry Wilmore critics say insecure uses
star Issa Ray's breakout web series
awkward black girl as the basis for an
insightful raunchy and hilarious Journey
Through the life of a 20-something black
woman that cuts her stereotypes with
sharp wit and infusive spirit
so am I still spending the night or no
oh
damn
what did I say
the only reason we came to them the red
ass club tonight so that you could hook
up with Daniel I don't even know I'm
gonna be there you knew this was always
about you it was about you two it's like
a joke to you no no real talk because
it's bad enough that I got to deal with
real trifling traditional mix on a daily
basis not to worry about dealing with a
trifling best friend
you made a joke of my heartbreak up
there I didn't mean to I didn't think
about it like that it's a damn problem
he said you don't start to think about
the [ __ ] you can actually affect others
are you kidding me
my whole life is about how it affects
others okay my job my boyfriend you
that's you too I always listen to you
[ __ ] you only do this to me because I
make you feel better about you
damn it
the [ __ ] I didn't even want to go
out tonight
here then I meet a decent dude you
should have seen how fast Jared left he
was the one oh that's right
that's right I'll never know never know
look at that [ __ ]
I didn't you're lying did you just send
a text message
I swear on my brother's life in my life
I did not send a text
number three master of none season one
Aziz Ansari plays the role of Dev a new
york-based actor who's struggling to
identify what he really wants both
personally and professionally the series
reveals glimpses of dev's younger years
and explores current aspects of his life
including modern etiquette and being
young and single in the city other
important people in dev's life are
featured including dev's parents
starring Ravi Patel Lena Wade and Aziz
Ansari who created the show with Alan
Yang critics say exceptionally executed
with charm humor and heart master of
none is a refreshingly offbeat take on a
familiar premise
whoever you're dating now at this stage
it could be who you end up with it's a
big decision it's hard how many women
did you meet before you decided online
two two that's it what was wrong the
first lady it's a little bit too tall as
soon as he stood up I was like whoa we
have to learn to make decisions man do
you want kids part of me is like yeah
it'd be an amazing experience
hey hey don't don't yell at people's
ethnicities
[Music]
there are a million things that guys
have no clue about that are so annoying
like what so you remember when we went
to brunch and we both Instagram a
picture of that frittata oh that
frittata was Fluffy as hell what are
your comments yum Town population Biz
check mine out I wanna [ __ ] your face
when you close your eyes do you see
Devin Rachel in a cozy house with little
Debs running around when you see black
number two fleabag season two
a dry-witted woman known as fleabag has
no filter as she navigates life and love
in London while trying to cope with
tragedy the angry grief riddled woman
tries to heal while rejecting anyone who
tries to help her but fleabag continues
to keep up her bravado through it all
starring Ben Aldridge CN Clifford Bill
Patterson and Phoebe wallerbridge who
also created the show critics say
fleabag jumps back into The Fray with a
bracing second season that upholds its
predecessors frenzied wit and delicate
heart replete with Phoebe Waller Bridges
indefatigable Charisma all right wine
everyone love someone you'll adore it I
chose it I'm not for us thanks off the
sauce six months and Counting why would
you do that we just enjoy each other
more this way
I haven't seen her since
except for
nice jumpsuit thank you you look well
where have you been boots
it's lovely there this time of year
oh you look fantastic oh you both look
gorgeous oh thank you is that fur yes
but it's okay because it had a stroke oh
lovely
I can't go to hell for that can I call
them no no as long as you confess oh God
he's their priest I need nothing to
[ __ ] worry about they're called
sweary priests love the Catholics you
can get away with anything a lot of them
did
it's an honor to be marrying you too
thank you I didn't realize you were
allowed out without your little doggy
thing oh sorry have I disappointed you
of course not devastated can you eat
another bottle needy waitress oh no it's
all right we've already ordered wine oh
tequila my name is Keila great thank you
so much can I get a glass of sparkling
water with a dash of lime please oh yes
I'll have the same
Dream Team
and before
number one here are some honorable
mentions
Jane the Virgin season one
Jane Villanueva the daughter of a teen
mother grew up determined not to repeat
her mom's mistakes Jane is studying to
be a teacher and she's engaged to a
handsome detective who supports her
decision to remain a virgin until
marriage but a routine visit to the
clinic turns her life upside down
inseminated by a specimen meant for a
patient in the Next Room Jane is in a
situation made only more insane when she
learns that the sperm donor is her boss
Raphael as her meticulously planned life
gets more like the telenovelas that she
loves she faces a lot of complicated
decisions about the future starring Gina
Rodriguez Andrea navedo Yael grobglass
Justin baldoni and developed by Jenny
Snyder Ehrman critics say Jane the
virgin's dubious premise has become part
of its unlikely charm along with
delightfully diverse writing and a
knockout performance by Gina Rodriguez
I had sex with Bruce three days ago what
why are you telling me this I don't know
what if you're like a religious Messiah
I can't lie to a religious Messiah
hey there Dr Oliver hi thank you for
seeing me it's the craziest thing right
these pregnancy tests keep coming back
positive and there's got to be a reason
right like some kind of hormonal thing
there is a reason
and the reason the test came back
positive is
I accidentally inseminated you two weeks
ago
you what it was a mistake I made a
mistake and there was only a 20 chance
that it would take so I I thought that
you would never know but things turned
out differently
[Music]
foreign
you're sorry you should be in jail lady
you should be locked up mom there's the
options this is a prescription for a
pill that you could take of course you
are under no obligation to consult with
the father but he does know
father
wait no I have to go the Americans
season three the Americans is a period
drama about the complex marriage of two
KGB spies posing as Americans in
Suburban Washington DC during the Reagan
Administration the arranged marriage of
Philip and Elizabeth Jennings grows more
passionate and genuine by the day but as
the pressures and demands of the job
grow heavier the personal toll becomes
almost too exhausting to Bear especially
when it comes to protecting their
american-born children they also face
the risk of Discovery by their friend
and neighbor FBI agent Stan Beeman who
is tasked with uncovering Soviet
illegals hiding in plain sight starring
Kerry Russell Matthew Reese Noah Emrick
and created by Joe Weisberg critics say
family driven drama and psychological
themes Propel the Americans totally
drawn tension dispensing Thrills of a
different ilk this season
it's an air conditioner
is it cold air yeah
I'm not ready
no I'm we're
supposed to be married now that's all
they'll expect us to have children
eventually or I don't know maybe just
maybe you just don't find me attractive
what do you think so far
I tell you everything then
I don't know when you see it it just
seems brighter
there's a weakness in the people
I can feel it
the good Place season four
in this final season Eleanor and her
friends must work together as a glooming
threat hangs over the good place
starring Kristen Bell Ted Danson Jamila
Jamil and created by Michael sure
critics say a wild philosophical ride to
the very end the good place brings it
home with a forking good final season
wow milkshake is incredible right this
is how I spend most of my time sitting
in beautiful places drinking my
milkshake slowly peeing into my pants
which instantly evaporates and leaves no
Trace sounds fun but didn't you want to
tell us how we're all screwed
damn it this is the exact problem on
paper this is Paradise all your desires
and needs are met but it's infinite and
when Perfection goes on forever you
become this glassy-eyed mush person but
no because
no because Patty no yes I'm telling you
oh man I studied so much things art and
music and the um the one with the number
piles where I'd be like two and you'd be
like six Math yes and then I came here
where time stretched out forever and
every second of my existence was amazing
but my brain became this big dumb blob
so we finally make it into the good
place and now we're just gonna become
zombies
why haven't you told anyone about this
about what dude damn it
damn it and finally number one only
murders in the building season one three
strangers share an obsession with True
Crime and suddenly find themselves
wrapped up in one when a grisly death
occurs inside their exclusive Upper West
Side apartment building the trio
suspects murder and employs their
precise knowledge of True Crime to
investigate the truth perhaps even more
explosive are the lies that they tell
one another soon the endangered Trio
comes to realize a killer might be
living among them as a race to decipher
the mountain Clues before it's too late
starring Martin Shore Selena Gomez and
Steve Martin who created the show with
John Hoffman critics say only murders in
the building silly approach to True
Crime obsessives is that once hilarious
and insightful thanks in large part to
its extremely Charming Central Trio hi
Howard
we just wanted to see how you were
holding up since Evelyn thank you
I wish I were dead
I'm sorry things have gotten a bit away
from me oh it's okay
um do you have another cat Mr Morris no
this is all Evelyn's if I don't touch
anything food water toys
I can pretend she's still here
you know I heard this once and maybe you
can appreciate it a cat never really
leaves you because they transmit
parasites
I'm sure Evelyn was very clean she was
thank you it seems like everyone in the
building loved her
[Music]
unlike Tim Kona
I'm sorry I just
I link them because they both died the
same day
right and people didn't really like Tim
cono no people did not
I hear
really what did you hear exactly just I
shouldn't speak ill of the Dead Tim was
a prick yes he certainly was
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
thank you
[Music]